hey everybody and welcome to the latest
episode of the Shan method this is the
show in which I Sean McGuinness display
open world games and just goof around
have fun do ridiculous [ __ ] and also
take suggestions from the chat room in
twitch and the comments and GameSpot so
if you want to contribute if you want to
have fun along with me you know get in
there and start talking to us today
we're playing Sleeping Dogs Chris waters
is on the couch today Chris waters is
not on the couch tonight Maxwell McGee
and I will be playing the part of Chris
waters you as his hands have just been
grafted to titanfall I've always says he
cannot remove them at this point what
you would die yes oh I don't like wait
hold on yeah I just like wow this is
gonna be the whole thing I don't like
how it looks like he's peeing on to us
when we cut to that oh look at this look
at this anybody duty it looks like he's
peeing on 20 it's like Oh rose okay
excess first things first first things
first before we venture out into the
wilds of Hong Kong I need to make sure
that I look the part you know what would
do like the sweet lion face it's pretty
green here's going to be top-heavy and
how Adam lies like the jacket and shorts
combo because it's the most confusing
combination is impossible where it's
like really my cold outside I should
take a jacket I'm not gonna take my
shorts off right cuz i wonder if i could
just go much completely pantsless
underpants you care if it but i also
have a bulky shine on the bottom in case
the weather you gotta run somewhere or
should I put on like really classy
loafers it smelling like raining outside
maybe you want step in a puddle yeah I
don't want to step in a puddle I could
wear my surgical man I could wear my
douchebag club guy glasses this is like
the guy who like hits on chicks and
dance clubs welcome to I could wear mine
oh no no we did is the worst all the
producers are having fun do you think
that we're ready to go and do u delta
you better go and stop a crime I'm gonna
go stop and don't have too hard a few
crimes okay first thing first need to
grab my gun never go out into the
streets without your gold 50 cal
pick that up on door I left I store it
on the ground yeah yeah you clean that
floor sweeping you keep sweeping that
floor keeping it here you missed a spot
it's right there right there clean that
up for me first I'm gonna drive around
with this door open yeah because this is
how like this is how you prep the way
that you're about to jump onto another
car but what I like to imagine okay yeah
girl you're in my fiction he's broken
his windshield I can imagine a few
things wrong with this so please be he's
broken his windshield is totally
shattered total spiderweb situation yeah
he can't see through it anymore so he's
driving around at 40 miles an hour
what's the door open up jump back in 72
popping out he's looking around like
this whoa he just make here we go we all
oh yeah just like that belly flop right
on oh there he goes moop so I'm just
gonna drive around and im gonna try to
clip pedestrians with my door that's
what just that's my heart racing goal
all right as anybody who's ever seen
call that we call that the Hong Kong
high five the Hong Kong high five yeah I
just gonna talk about this guys ready
look it posted for high five right there
oh yeah oh you can just do an immediate
beer left or right which is via it's
essentially punching other cars with
your car um look like a cop you can top
if you wanted to and then you just drive
around with your door open like this and
then when you get tired of being in a
car you're like peace oh yeah yeah I
don't need that car anymore also I don't
worry every word this guy's smoking and
I need to teach him a little lesson
about about his nose taking care of your
lungs yeah I'm good to your body do you
know what else is dangerous sir oh no
this me walking me walking you out into
traffic reception aggressive shoving you
like this I'm gonna I'm just gonna hold
you in this intersection yeah this is
what you're doing to your loan this is
what happened this is what happens this
is what happens this is your lungs how
do you think your lungs feel your lungs
are essentially being held hostage could
you toss this do because I feel like you
need to show them how his lungs for you
oh yeah oh don't worry about that i'm
about to show this guy how his lungs
feel
no and then you took yeah bit of a joy
hop well the hop was a metaphor for when
you die and go to heaven but I'm not
ready to go to heaven you know bring you
by you made the buzz vibrate wash
trembling in fear of your mighty bus
kicking ability is Hong Kong of them
whoa 50 come on come on flip it over
come on come on wake up you're Jack you
gotta run gotta run maybe we should
hitch a ride on one of those taxi cabs
oh I'm gonna go down this way they're
never gonna find me here here we go the
thing is like the lack of pants makes my
running yeah a lot much more nimble that
much fan much much more nimble well I'm
gonna get on this freeway and try to
outrun a cop oh I know oh wait haven't I
have an idea wise idea here we go
perfect crime I'm good oh you see I'm
good o.o what just bounced off the
ground when you land and your ankles are
gonna be all wreck a hold on you I gotta
I gotta take different least our faces
and you never flush your toilet mother
no why would I ever want to do that the
government would find my secrets gonna
be so wrong Garos you get oh it's gonna
just fill the apartment with that no I'm
a doctor doctor I know what I'm doing
thank you very much I'll be dr. shoves
we're gonna take a walk to the ocean
because I'm a doctor and you have a
sickness and the only prescription is
being in the ocean here we go like how
nobody is coming to the first base oh
they cuz all those guys know that this
guy is a huge piece of [ __ ] and they
don't feel bad at all that he's about to
get chucked into the ocean just doing a
little bit of street justice oh no no
sounds like okay thanks Oh what this
long to bite me you hauled off and
kicking the please please nobody fights
oh [ __ ] eat that lamb dunk yeah there
you go
make sure he's dead oh there's a there's
a ghost inside this shipping container I
think there's like thinking me I think
you need to go in there and ghost bus
the [ __ ] I ghost bust those you need to
go ghost bus this news i do you think
that these are like people who are being
shipped to Russia to become like mail
order brides mmm i was thinking more
like I mean always coming to this
country oh they could be parts unknown
parts unknown yeah I mean I feel like
there is some like human trading going
on here well I feel like I need to save
this person yeah get out get out you
hang on i'll punch through the walls
already you oh no he's a four man did
you panic in my party oh no through the
wall oh come on come on you do it you
can do it come on you freedom is so
close just finish doing come on you
won't be some Russian men's mail-order
bride but I will save you sir this guy
really wants his freedom and I want to
give them escrito free come on buddy go
come on I'm gonna open this latch for
you just kick the boss he's just caught
in there you have an idea I'm gonna
shoot you out of there it's you might
you might wing him why are you just
really are asking for help that was a
real wild card move all right here we go
here we go ready oh oh that guy got with
the fear God who we're gonna get you
we're gonna get you ere we go just
loosen them up just loosen my loosey
goose Oh what loosey goosey come on
buddy you can do okay let's see what
happens when I do this seven works come
on come on now male mana name on it big
money no neither one of the Roosters
goes out of the Rope circle is that what
I look like sumo wrestling that's what I
was to nash's last time I don't know oh
come on also doesn't realize instance we
got the same don't get tourney you are
he's getting are you doing what are you
going the fight is in chair the game air
we hear ya
ah fake out right total fake out his
life my money back oh and I got look at
those achievements i got chivos yeah
this is you're right this is probably
unacceptable oh she's a tourist oh oh oh
no oh here we go there we go ambulance
the crime was over here let me show you
show you it's this way down here don't
worry this is the woman who needs a help
you see can you give her emergency care
thank you please I think you need to
display hold on sir we're the wound him
you've got a phone so good oh no I don't
feel like you're really done oh no oops
it wasn't for you it was for your friend
sir please I need some assistance this
is where I need to be sure i'll head
here you just come Holly right if she
were standing right there you just come
skidding it oh hi why is your face all
messed up where do you want to go I
don't care as long as we get the driest
all right I know a good place it's the
docks strike fast excited to get I'm
sure excited all right yeah he strike at
date you throw him in the keister open
the way you think what you're saying
through you just call people and throw
them into the haha hey oh it's okay I'm
here with you hole-in-one okay that's
the end of today's show things have
gotten really crazy but thank you guys
for watching that was a lot of fun I had
a lot of fun that was a good time that's
good it's sleeping dogs it's a really
fun game you know we were just goofing
around but this was actually one of my
very favorite games of 2012 and it's
kind of it was a little bit overlooked
the time it came out but I do recommend
checking it out see if it's on sale on
steam I know it's probably like six
dollars on steam it's probably pretty
cheap definitely recommend it's a lot of
fun alright that does it for the Shan
method make sure that you guys tune in
to gamespot tomorrow yeah for Chris
waters show multiple players at 11am
followed by the lobby omar was random
encounter yesterday was reliable
weak mixed up she did I'm mixing up
Tuesday and Thursday make sure to tune
in tomorrow at 11am for random encounter
starring Daniel Dwyer and then come out
with it come back next Tuesday apple
into the few chicks Tuesday for multiple
players and the lobby yes Maxwell McGee
thank you for co-hosting thank you for
having me all right everybody uh see you
guys later